Saludos desde el Aeropuerto
Internacional El Dorado de Bogotá donde
la situación es dramática igual que en
otros aeropuertos de Colombia como el de
Medellín y Barranquilla el lunes por la
noche viva Air la compañía low cost
colombiana paralizó su actividad después
de 11 años en el aire denuncian una
situación financiera crítica y también
el hecho de que no les hayan permitido
ser absorbidos por Avianca por su parte
la aeronáutica civil asegura que esta
fusión podría vulnerar las leyes de
monopolio en medio 5000 empleos y
centenares de pasajeros como Abigail que
está aquí en el aeropuerto del dorado es
de México y pensaba llegar hasta Leticia
cómo te sientes Abigail Y cómo han sido
los daños para ti la verdad un poquito
decepcionada porque he estado planeando
mucho este viaje y de la nada que te
cancelen justo ayer y va a ser el
check-in y sale el anuncio de que todo
está cancelado y yo pues no sé tenía
como que pues enojo rabia y dije
seguramente nos van a dar una solución
rápido pero lo que me sorprende Es que
la aerolínea no ha dicho nada o sea como
que se deslindo de todo por lo que pues
tocó venir aquí al aeropuerto a ver qué
información nos daban porque fue la
única forma fuimos con latam ya todo
está lleno y pues bueno Ahora estoy
probando aquí con Avianca a ver si
encuentro solución porque sí quiero ir
realmente
Abigail pretendía llegar al Leticia la
capital del Amazonas y dicen que están
recolocando a los usuarios a los
pasajeros de viva Air en Avianca Atena y
también en latam Abigail de momento Qué
información tienes cuando era previsto
tu vuelo cuando piensas que vas a poder
llegar a Leticia mi vuelo era para
mañana en la mañana De hecho viva él ya
había cambiado los vuelos
dos veces pero dije no no creo que pase
algo y pues bueno pasó y finalmente con
lata me dicen que puedo volar si es que
se liberan lugares hasta el 2 de marzo
Pero obviamente eso afecta todo mi
itinerario porque tengo los días
contados
la situación de viva erres bebe también
de la crisis de la pandemia económica
crees que también las aerolíneas es una
muestra más del abuso hacia el usuario
definitivamente porque Incluso en la
mañana
Pensé en comprar un vuelo y se
dispararon O sea si de por sí eran ya
estaban caros por la poca disposición
ahora se voltearon o sea se duplicaron
Entonces era como que imposible comprar
otro vuelo y sobre todo si vas como con
lo justo si este tipo de situaciones te
sacan totalmente de control Gracias por
tus testimonios y te deseo la mayor de
la suerte para que puedas viajar pero
lograr
devolvemos la conexión al estudio Andrés